[Music]
it started here high in the mountains
months ago record accumulation of snows
piled up but downstream the runoff water
was being kept above the dams now lake
mead is rising at several inches a day
at overton beach joe hansen may be the
first restaurateur on the lake after the
drive through
we sat here and talked many of us a
month or two ago and said in here and
wondered how come they let the lake
build up on top of the dams this one
pile harvest was all
real high they let it build up and they
still they knew they had that big
snowpack but whatever the reasoning of
federal officials the water is here
johansen will be shutting down his
business
you could lose
business naturally fourth is one of our
big days
looks like the summer's killed you know
others will lose their homes this is
overton beach mobile home park it is one
of the residential areas on the lake
which will be hit the hardest people who
live here say this street will be under
water in a couple of days this is the
first time those wheels on anna roth's
mobile home have turned in 14 years
where do you put the blame for this
having to move after all these years
bureau of reclamation
and they they knew it they knew the
water was going up it's never been this
high before
the engineers say the water should crest
at 1225 feet that would put the surface
of lake mead right at maple barneson's
doorstep that's what the engineers say
are you bitter about this
yes because i don't think it had to be
i think it was just poor management
with our bureau of
reclamation and land management
i i can't say any other thing now you
have plans to come back here definitely
if the water goes down
and it's back to normal i want to come
back i've lived here 23 years
but no one knows exactly how long the
lake level will stay up exactly how much
further it will go we'll talk about some
of the spin-off effects for overton
beach and surrounding areas tomorrow
mark fiero eyewitness news eight
the lake is rising the good beaches and
the boat ramps are disappearing
underwater this is not a boat ramp it's
a parking lot with a lake rising you
pick a good parking spot when you leave
for that weekend trip or you're the
instant owner of a submarine just a few
days ago rangers were still optimistic
not many are showing much concern about
launching the boats because the park has
stated we'll make every effort to keep
the launch ramps themselves open
and here we can do it we can
use the parking area that was a few days
ago now rangers are stationed at the
launch sites to regulate traffic on what
is left of the launch ramps the high
water has crested completely over the
break water at echo bay workers are
laboring feverishly to build the
breakwater above the rising lake level
without the breakwater millions of
dollars worth of boats at echo bay would
be violently slammed about in the event
of high winds and the rising water has
changed the complexion of the lake the
old salts that know the lake like the
back of their hands now have new
obstacles to contend with the shoreline
there will be real problems when
officials begin lowering the lake level
the shoreline which has been under water
for days will then be exposed that is
expected to play havoc with a bass bond
we'll have more on fishing a major
attraction of the lake tomorrow mark
fiero eyewitness news eight
if you're thinking about fishing on lake
mead this weekend don't let the high
water stop you there are a few anglers
out there who may blame their bad luck
on the rising lake level but park
officials say the numbers just don't
bear out the negative claims
it isn't bothering the fishing a bit
creole census taker was here today and
he's reporting about what he always does
the fishermen are still out and still
catching the fish lest you think that's
just some massaging from the bureaucrats
the locals say the same sparky perkins
grew up in nearby overton he says the
rising water may help it's lowering the
lake that may throw a wrench into your
creel i know that it'll be good for
fishing it'll make fishing real good i
know that uh in the past times every
time they raise the lake they lower the
lake and it ruins
the bass spawn and it could have a great
effect as far as
if there was to take and drop the lake
clear back down right now
but lowering the water is not the
immediate problem for now the lake
continues to rise a favorite fishing
spot for some black canyon directly
behind the dam has now been closed to
boaters completely and bureau of
reclamation officials have now revised
their estimates of just where the lake
will peak by another two and a half feet
these pictures were taken saturday this
concession stand at overton beach is now
half underwater federal officials now
expect water to begin pouring over the
spillways at hoover dam either late
sunday or early monday morning that's
the first time that has happened since
1941. mark fierro eyewitness news eight
only once before has water seeped over
these spillways that was in 1941 when
the government successfully tested their
operation
but this year the bulging colorado river
filled the lake mead reservoir and the
water came tumbling down
the site brought three times the number
of visitors to the dam and tourism
officials are expecting record crowds
over the next few weeks as the cascading
waters rise another three or four feet
i think it's amazing i've never seen
anything like it before
neither have residents downstream who
complain that this site is proof the
bureau of reclamation mishandled control
of the colorado this spring
john pilot a boulder city resident was
one of the original workers on the dam
project he saw the spillways operate in
1941 and he returned to the dam to watch
them again
well i'm just sorry to see that it
happens
personally
because a control of the flood waters is
in real bad danger at this time
water flow through the dam's power
plants must now be reduced to compensate
for this spillage bureau of reclamation
officials say the overflow could lead to
a complete shutdown of hoover's
generators in the next few weeks that
would be the first shutdown in the
plant's 47 year history
but officials are hoping that won't
happen they will try to maintain a
steady 40 000 cubic feet per second flow
of water from the dam and say that early
signs are encouraging
well at this time we're hopeful to keep
the
increases if any at the downstream level
to a minimum we do know that the inflow
is dropping it's a little early to tell
but at this point it looks encouraging
officials will collect data over the
next few days to determine the extent of
water releases and although the swollen
colorado river poses no threat to the
structure of hoover dam it could
continue to take its toll on
flood-ravaged communities downstream
cindy benson eyewitness news 8.